today I am so excited because we're
gonna watch you and I my favorite stream
of all time
it is so goddamn painful to watch but
that's how you know that [ __ ] is good
the thing about streams is that once the
content is up there it's there forever
and that's the beauty of it I I'm always
extremely paranoid
whenever I stream that I'm going to say
something or do something that people
will judge me
anyway let's we'll laugh at some other
people being awkward all right so this
stream is for summer games done quick
2014 it's a speedrun of tomba 2 single
kid look at that I'm credible don't get
me wrong I think speedruns can be really
interesting oh my god my camera is so
don't get me wrong I'm not here to trash
speedruns I think it can be really
interesting and really impressive what
people do with their spare time cuz
jesus [ __ ] christ I'm kidding I'm
kidding
now let's go back to the video I was
100% sure it said autistic there because
I think it takes a special kind of mind
to do this game this looks fun so we got
cavemen the guy with a mustache and what
I and the guy next to him chibi who
invited himself on the couch for the
speedrun now imagine imagine playing the
same game over and over and over and
over and over and over and it's your
time it's the only skill you have it's
the only talent you really acquire which
is one talent more than I at will ever
have so don't get me wrong but still
imagine doing all that it's your time to
shine it's your time to show it all off
and then this [ __ ]
chibi invites himself to the couch next
to you to steal your spotlight let's
watch hello everyone I am caveman dcj
this is tomba 2 that's a good start I
mean it's more about that mob he has so
chibi keeps trying to fill fill in the
blanks you know which I can respect
chibi for doing
first of all chibi it's the only guy man
I love how chibi it's the only guy
manspreading he clearly went all out
laying on this couch
but camon he's not having it I always
usually wear pajama pants but I would
say we're jeans today yeah you're not
dressed for the occasion
I mean I I mean they were fanatic I
recommend all viewers to go get a nice
cup of joe perhaps a bagel dude I love
bagels is sit back and enjoy some
breakfast combo asiago cheese bagel
yummy I believe you dude I love bagels
it's so yummy I believe you we barely
getting started and Kay men seem a
little bit fed up by chibi we all met
that one guy that thinks he knows
everything and wants to comment about
[ __ ] he doesn't know what he's talking
about
well that's chibi for you the character
the design of this game kind of reminds
me of adventure island alright you know
a little social lab a little social
school from your boy
PewDiePie ultimate social socialist I
mean I mean ultimate social person if
you're doing most of the talking and the
person you're speaking to gives most of
the responses like okay uh-huh alright
then that probably means they are not
interested in anything of what you're
saying and you should probably ask them
a question instead I know I know
I'm very well versed in the art of
social interaction all right well we
have $20 from I'm iffy here's $20 you
can have it maybe it'll come in useful
and we have $5 I'm going to Khalil e
boomerang height for you gachi B you're
so awkward and my man should be here
some excellent stand-up comedy
on-the-fly skills just look at look at
this so this is the case we're getting
crabs is a good thing yeah mom a QB yeah
crabs is a good thing oh look how happy
is why is he smiling so much there were
some crabs ula animal ever again that is
the end of the crab section of the wrong
ripped crab and hopefully the end of you
TV I'm kidding I'm kidding yes fast
pants they need to go fast I want one
now
excuse me chibi Pence is actually plural
not a lot of people know about this that
is the [ __ ] morons it even said pants
for you to go oh yeah I would hate to
actually like have to put the pants on
I mean alright with that risk ap Apple I
gotta go I mean I could always wear the
payment uh she'd be just go no one wants
your hair Chiba we have $20 from Ewing
I'm so happy
any form of attention he just lifts up
chiba god bless you and lonely a lonely
child you know the only child in the
family that's chiba right there you know
it's true you know it's true tom be
squirrel suit hype donating another five
dollars if the announcer can pronounce
my name right
holy i was closed
yeah gilina cold tell me with an I know
you know I liked how he had said a
little he hesitated a little better to
do that mean look at him he's like
should I do a cheeky should I do a
cheeky chippy look at him look at him
it goes in cheeky Nicole Tony goddamn
jokes Rob Rob so good so good it doesn't
actually talk though we would never say
that in any situation scroll oh my god
you could pretend to this this is
painful I have said Ben Oh turbo
translator that's a moment where you
just need to be quiet like they had a
little nice conversation there like a
little bit of back and forth interaction
but then he just has to keep going now
you're just making me excited I don't
think you're ready for that I don't
think I am just stop there just stop
there to Pete and say nothing more I
think I need some time to prepare my
body and you some fun [ __ ] [ __ ]
goddammit never doubt the powers of
weapon space alright alright someone
else has a birthday today what are the
odds right with chibis birthday I never
realized that maybe that's why Cayman is
trying to be nice at some point you know
it's chibis birthday I got it that makes
this even better yes
since when did super mario brothers and
you get here so joke oh my god you know
it's a good joke when you don't laugh
and instead you just say with a dead
tone good joke that's how you know
something is truly hilarious so at this
point how long have they been playing 18
minutes it's not even that long they're
supposed to go for an hour 30 and came n
it's not having it anymore
he the cringe has gone too far
it needs to stop he needs to do
something so Joe GB is not picking up on
any of the social cues that taught air
that came n has been giving him to shut
the [ __ ] up so
ferm santas number one helper is a
squirrel I would really prefer I God Oh
bless my favorite moment ever it's so
mean but it's so justified at the same
time here's the thing though I'm not on
either side okay I'm a little bit
towards came inside because if he
invited himself through the cash that's
[ __ ] annoying but at the same time I
feel bad for chibi and I also think
they're both you know sort of in the
wrong I guess in a way
okay so literally thirty minutes later a
little less than thirty minutes later I
guess he's been quiet for 30 minutes
it's just been sitting there moping it's
his birthday he's not happy
this is terrible he's sunken into the
couch any sense from two streams I want
to hear more of the guy in the green
sweatshirt on the couch please let him
talk more yeah I like how caiman like
gives him permission to speak hi oh my
god it's so awkward I can't
nice mustache thank you so since you
have all the take bags that mean
justified all the buses now long yep
boss rush mode why did this random girl
to show up with a paper dollars from
died aside enjoying the front but I'll
donate another $10 if green hoodie guy
does 10 jumping jacks green hoodie guy
do those jump oh he still has to be like
the cool I told you he's so happy
whenever he gets a ten-time is frozen so
this is just pretty much to the point of
no return
I like the first thing you see those are
not jumping jacks
hahahaha oh this is turning me on oh my
lord I don't know great job guy I don't
know you spend an hour together next to
each other on a couch and you're really
bonded you truly bonded thanks guys you
just gave me my exercise of the week
it's AMA too background music complement
the Alcorn it so well dude I've got um
chibi thank you for the evil list of
pigs in video games such as welcome City
Kong Racing Zelda mother thank you for
the list of evil take the videos we're
welcome I mean you did act he did ask it
did ask okay I'm just trying to process
all this which side are you on
team chippy Oh team caveman this
happened years ago no one gives a [ __ ]
anymore
here's caveman's response did I get mad
[ __ ] after my tomba 2 run the short
answer is no the long answer is thank
[ __ ] god no from what I understand
his name was chibi he still plays tomba
how can you still play tom from what I
understand his name was chibi which is
an excellent name for a man that is an
excellent name for a man I told him to
be quiet because he was a [ __ ] and I
didn't ask for him to be on the couch
and he just invited himself on and sat
shoulder length to me so I couldn't move
my elbows and just would not shakers God
god forbid your elbows touch that would
just be make it even more awkward [ __ ]
oh he did anyone see him actually doing
those jumping jacks yeah
like Jesus Christ at least like at least
do good proper jumping jack that that
was TVs main mistake he did not do
proper jumping jacks oh it makes me
angry every - aching every time no one
does a proper came from jerk oh now if
you don't have enough sympathy for TV
yet here's a here's a ten minute video
of his mom interrupting his speedrun of
Paper Mario no actually it doesn't
well he really needs to tell his mom
here is excuse me
I am playing video games slightly faster
than your average person mom you need to
back out back up I am living my life
right now let's finish this just so you
guys don't think I'm [ __ ] on all
over these people actually I am 100%
this clip is my favorite speed run this
is to me
interesting speed runs because you get
hyped as [ __ ] and just wash your shame
RRL time me and Marc root sue me and
[ __ ] Mark Reuss ooh that's [ __ ]
right I skipped 1:13 I'm a [ __ ]
legend
I've never seen a 1:13 and I never
[ __ ] will 1:12 baby - - [ __ ] suck
apparently he got 1:12 time I got a
[ __ ] look from this map [ __ ]
and I cuts the goddamn grenade launcher
then the commentary so [ __ ] legendary
[Music]
because apparently that's like I can
believe the lowest you can get on this
map right here this is the 112 right
here yes and I hadn't been done before
or whatever I'm gonna have to do someone
have the fun Axl
they won rush what a rush
[Music]
watch
ha
okay words I was just about to point
that out right in the [ __ ] head gonna
[ __ ] 1:12 baby that's right you see
that clutch Nick I have been actualized
much look at this [ __ ] line I think I
might yeah baby
[ __ ] through this I wait I wait I
wait ray when he starts firing to try to
backboost means the double body armor
two quick ones I already know I'm
getting there on the perfect line I'm
right the [ __ ] pay fifty forty nine
the body baby yeah that's [ __ ] it
[ __ ] palms watching this one again I
waited to cinema to cuz I said oh my god
my new ones well it's [ __ ] it it's
[ __ ] is baby oh so good [ __ ] puts
me in hype mode every time i watch it
but yet there you go that's that some
awkward and some awesome speedrunning
for you guys let me know in the comments
who was whose side are you on Team GB or
team caveman I think I'm leaning towards
cavemen but I think they're both equally
artistic also check out crow be cat for
finding this video and putting it
together that's all for me for now thank
you guys so much for watching
and it's always sister Fitz there